Oh what's this kids oh this is another
excuse to do weird stuff again isn't it
well your last excuse did result in
Beetlejuice and that was if they
critical and box office in okay you can
take the rest of the day doing another
one budget there's another excuse to do
weird stuff again isn't it
okay well the last time you did this you
made little monster and that wasn't
nearly as good so I want you to try a
lot harder this time okay I'm sure
they'll get it this time around your
last film what school world cool there's
only so many times you can use this
excuse for doing weird stuff just for
the sake of doing weird stuff and giving
you one more chance if this next one
isn't nearly as good as Beetlejuice
you're both in big trouble alright
[Music]
did you enjoy monkey Bo
I will not breathe I will not breathe
well how can you accomplish that if
you're saying it
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
sometimes we like to give in to the dark
and weird simply because it's dark and
weird some directors are so good at
creating them it's how they make their
living giving us visually goofy oddly
nonsensical yet somehow massively
entertaining madness there's a right way
and a wrong way to do it and after a
while the novelty of the strange wears
off and we see what still holds up and
what doesn't
films like gremlins Addams family and
ParaNorman still hold up feels like
monkey bone monkey bone and monkey bone
do not it's hard to say why some of
these other weird films work but it's
very easy to see why this weird film
doesn't despite it being visually
stunning and surreal it's annoying as
false it's loud it's stupid it's a good
thing to talk to did these films because
much like a trippy coma I don't know how
far I can go before I couldn't come back
so why is this the one that killed the
weird and dark movies for a while let's
take a look with monkey bone it was
third grade you know how some teachers
have those Glatz on their arms I began
to feel aroused instantly sold the
rhesus monkey bone I'm so glad Cartoon
Network finally greenlit and our chrome
Christmas so once the price the title
wasn't merry krumitz or beware of the
compass honestly I'm not even really
joking this is a new kid show that's
going to hit television called monkey
bone isn't this just the audience you
would expect applauding a show like this
move over Samantha our new Sex in the
City is monkey bone look at this there's
even tons of kids merchandise there that
certain it's going to be a hit every
kid's going to want three they're going
to want their friends to have three
otherwise they're not gonna be friends
anymore
ah yeah for this to feel aroused you
have no idea how excited kids are to see
what duck man giving up looks like you
know aside from the first time the human
representation the 90s trying to die in
the 2000s try and begin or as you call
them David Bowie addresses the crowd and
introduces the creator of the comic
strip the show is based on still
played by brendan fraiser he did not
draw that you lying sack of suck he did
not come up with any of what we just saw
oh come on there's usually good-looking
characters in these weird dark film yeah
why doesn't it work he's our back in all
those other films the main character was
quirky but still normal the grounding
reality to offset the strangeness that
the rest of the film is about to throw
at you but Fraser is already supposed to
be weird and awkward and tormented the
crazy geek behind the odd cartoons tell
me if even for a nanosecond you believe
he's that kind of guy
the cool thing is that you open it you
go out it closes and you can't get back
in okay every bad no no she's so
believable just look at his chiseled
smiling action-hero demeanor that's so
represents the shy artist there's a good
but if later got your sooner it would be
a lot better all right we get it
I mean not since Woody Allen or Paul
Giamatti have I so bought the
introverted uncomfortable social outcast
this much look at this no you know that
is leave oh the monkey never had any
good luck we get it we won't choose
someone like him ever again and what do
we say about breathing he's about to
propose to his girlfriend played by
Bridget Fonda again representing the
weirdo loser who gets lost in his own
awkwardness we said we're sorry back and
he tries to get her to leave the place
because you know this social stuff is so
hard on him he's totally gonna bench
alas if he talks anymore
oh I mean in between is weird cartooning
everybody loves you come on advice by
the way don't have a background that's
more interesting than your foreground
like most of you I'm not listening to a
thing they're saying and instead trying
to figure out what episode of Simpsons
that crusty frame is from I know I seen
that one before is it after season seven
I stopped watching after season said I I
mean I watch but you know wasn't as guys
when it started to go downhill I mean
okay never officially jump the shark a
name oh I don't know that won't take
Skinner that I kind of tremble to char
bone spur
never doing money vote but one of the
pieces of merchandise a giant inflatable
raft that overused market
I thought they'd yank though is after
people were disturbed sitting outdoors
face goes off and since their car
crashing into a wall Frasier and sent
into a coma while Fonda is completely
untouched the car was a giant air bag
how was he knocked out as Frasier an
Activision Hillston become familiar with
watching himself die
now we're right downtown welcome you to
downtown and why you're in your coma no
boy you're not going to take that
background overshadowing the foreground
advice are you boys and girls of every
age question designers were overly paid
Wow hey bud hey mate okay movie I'll
make a deal with you mix all the actors
and just leave a 360 camera in the
middle of a set I'll call it even
yeah for all its faults this world is
pretty damn amazing this place is called
downtown where people go when they're in
comas that's apparently ran on people's
Nightmares and apparently everyone
watched the same episode of Japan's
pee-wee's Playhouse to come up with
these images while live in some Marvel
for the eyes it's a DC for the rest of
the senses as Friedrich comes across his
creation monkey bone voiced by a sped-up
John Tudor oh I know you're all in coma
but my first guest is Mike Young Josh
what's the difference in speeding up to
toros voice and really any blaze voice
to sound exactly the same
Kotaro cause more and trust me casting a
big-name actor to do the voice doesn't
distract how ball grading lis annoying
is on a bone the lady got a repo boat
get on the Judah trace Humboldt okay I'm
over the novelty of him being
stop-motion now I hate him
[Music]
anyone else created to work out the
sexually toons of the director and/or
writer open guys not just me
so phrase your sister played by Megan
Mullaly wants to pull the plug on him
why no that's not figurative I'm
actually asking you why you buy him as
much understanding as I do as far as I
can tell she just wants to kill a man
there's no motivation the film gives as
to why I mean okay she says they made a
pact because their father died so slowly
but she seems way too excited and eager
I don't really get it well I'm sure
sweetheart which one's the plug what was
the plug but it's dark so it's funny
yeah it's dark but only funny if we
understand why this is the first time
we've seen her we don't know what their
relationship is like or even what she's
like because we don't know why she's
acting this way or this is how she
normally act or what there's no context
yeah but we blackmail Bridget Fonda into
being in this that's kind of calvert
okay
the doctor says after three months it's
less likely someone will come back from
a coma so three months pass as shown by
this dissolve
I thought felt more like a two and a
half month dissolved but I still got the
general passage of time as Fraser
continues to train for how to not be
funny in Looney Tunes back in action you
have Milly ated me in public for the
last time about that rock in the pot you
know I'm just gonna say it what's the
appeal of this guy I mean I know he's
good-looking and he played the likeable
doofus okay but looking back on his work
I can't say he's awful but I don't
really say he's good either just look at
this scene where he's supposed to act
like monkey bone is in front of him
that's it
back in the pack like I have my body
back I think Brendan Fraser is the less
convincing puppet does it effort seem
like he's walking at this thing Kneebone
he's acting with other actors it just
seems like George's a jungle light he
got an exit pass where's mine yeah what
do I get to go home he gives the
performance a million other actors could
give it never seems distinctly unique
kidding
I'm never gonna get out of here to its
credit though I don't know if any acting
can make scenes like this work ah the
days when adult humor and animation was
a novelty a monkey jumping in a woman's
booth
those are cartoons the best things of a
Shadrin on three there and things are
interrupted though when one of the
people in a coma is sent back to the
living oh I have God I'm the ghost of
Christmas missteps I'm here to convince
Michael Caine he can act with Muppets
the man is sent back to the real world
through the mouth of Abraham Lincoln
because because well you didn't think of
it so it's clever yeah come here
did you know that if your knuckles are
pink you're more likely to be a genius
ah well please get better
Frasier wants to figure out how he can
get an exit path so he goes to a pajama
party of hypnose the lord of dreams who
loves the nightmares Frasier comes up
with
[Music]
again if the story could just politely
leave and we could play a Rammstein song
over them I think we could have
something what's the film insists it has
a narrative as Hypno's tells Frasier
where it again exit pass tak tak no life
support
I just forgot a spleen this octet not
leaving anybody got some that serves my
god could you please shut up your Roger
Rabbit I know he has a name but it's
just your Roger Rabbit
hypno says if he travels to the land of
the dead he can steal an exit path for
himself what Fonda's convinced he's
still in there trying to get out
everybody here know what Honor X is
nightmares oops
do you think we can decrease the levels
so I want to give him more when even a
massive dose I'm going to scare him away
you want scare him awake show them the
reviews for single white female oh is it
all seriousness you are a treasure what
are you doing in this movie Frasier
disguises himself as a wicker tampon and
sneaks in to see the Grim Reaper point
by Whoopi Goldberg and her assistant
played by Thomas Haden Church I'm yours
what do you want let's get to reap it
let's go we're the paycheck in between
two big things they steal the exit path
resulting in Whoopi's head exploding
thank you now that I'm leaving there's
so many things that I wanted to say to
you we really should have been working
on our chemistry instead of having the
background eat us alive Oh monkey bone
betrays him by stealing the egg to pass
and going into Frazier's body in the
real resulting in the real Frazier being
put away so like most boners you think
it's your friend but it often gets you
in trouble and sometimes even lands you
in prison
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so not lucky bone is in Brendan Fraser's
body all the possibilities this opens up
I be propitious so many defining
character traits of monkey bone like he
silly he's horny he likes to dress like
Marilyn Monroe for some reason honestly
I probably get more character out of the
peach from SELEX last movie than this so
we have a not very defined character now
being portrayed by a not very defined
actor don't get me wrong he's clearly
trying he's jumping all over the place
and screaming and such but I guess
that's kind of expected nothing is
really added to make it his own even the
spin take just seems run-of-the-mill
Oh mom it's a spit-take there has to be
more life and isn't that part of what
makes those work is the unexpectedness I
don't even know where I came from it
gets even more uncomfortable when Fonda
tries to seduce him what a peculiar way
to seduce a man this is what I call the
pg-13
[Music]
laughing yep yeah I think Vaughn does
look up whoever speaks for all of us
no stop showing that this is not worth
whatever impact you think it's having on
us come on ah okay I will die a happy
man a less angry man I will not die if
you never show me that again I'll thank
God one of those Hope transitions
finally had a good use we want it's got
to move fast in this crowd you'll starve
Fraser thrown in prison with a ton of
crazy mind to create great nightmares
including Stephen King who says Cujo
stole his body like monkey bone did when
he was in a coma I went to hell to get
that exit pass and who got to use it
Cujo yeah I always wonder why Stephen
King's last five books were just bark
bark bark how about that nightlight I
asked for to make things weirder that's
the actual Stephen King playing himself
in the movie okay it's not but a minute
you were throwing the IMDB back but
Hypno's infiltrates monkey bones dream
to remind him that this is also he could
spread more nightmares around the world
we help him swipe your body he comes get
a heap of brand-new diapers that's right
this guy who had maybe three minutes of
screen time
he's our villain now oh there's so many
complex motivations and personalities
going on in this film like why the hell
chucky cheese genetically melted into
barf the dog it's his movies asking
questions I didn't need to be asked some
monkey bone tries to find that nightmare
Jews brought up before and fourth it on
people all over the world okay if that
poncho is indicating this is all a
secret sequel to unbreakable I'm totally
opting out of the Shyamalan Cinematic
Universe
[Music]
thank you came in at a pretty penny the
radar a Batman everybody no seriously
Sam hey I'm the guy who wrote Batman
also wrote this I actually hate to say
it but it makes a little too much sense
the feeling wants to release a gas on
everybody disguised in a giant cartoon
while a sexy cat woman comes in suddenly
designed she's in love with the main
character and McDonald's wants to attach
their Happy Meal rights to a franchise
sure to have children wet their beds
maybe Keaton saves those movies more
than I thought
keep those movies credit though they did
spend an entire 90 seconds
congratulating themselves on a farting
monkey doll oh and you get right I
counted
[Music]
just for that you get the button monkey
bone test a nightmare juice on the pet
dog giving it what else a nightmare whoa
cat videos on the dark web are creepier
than I expected
he puts the doll with the gas inside a
giant statue of his character and
[Music]
[Applause]
homey the clown that was the Simpsons
episode man that crunchy frame
driving me nuts on that scene sucked so
as mentioned the cat lady breaks Frasier
out of prison only to immediately be
caught again they don't even show on
being caught it's off screen so why'd
you have them escape at all someday
we'll find it the screenplays connection
the author's intention maybe I'm a
simple person I do an honest day's work
why does everybody make it so hard for
me that is literally what would be said
every day of shooting
Frasier sob story wins her over though
so she sends him back via SNL actor
trying way too hard where our life in a
shot that could crap out there Mike's
better Chris Kattan is now playing our
hero for a bit and to be fair his
physical comedy is pretty good playing a
gymnast whose neck is broken so he has
to keep finding ways to prop it up this
bits been done literally to death but he
does pull it off okay I'm just waiting
to see where the better call Saul story
line is going to fit in
hey meanwhile fully gets a whiff of the
nightmare juice from the farting monkey
bone toy yeah what the hell is this
stuff
oh look is what Henry Selick said after
every rewrite he starts seeing his
nightmares in real life because let's
face it this is all just an unused
Freddy Krueger scrimped close the turkey
don't work a together
you're really gonna regret that this was
the film you went naked for oh excuse me
I almost interrupted the master tonight
package your misdirection ladies and
gentlemen forget about the naked man
with the purple faith hold an old joke
but wait it's an early two-thousands Bay
FL dance number time
a woman needs oh you forgot to ask the
shadow of the cameraman if he wanted to
dance the more he continues to be DOA
dated on arrival Catan literally swings
his way in because even though it's
supposed to be freighters mind and there
he suddenly knows gymnastics we can
contend even more credit though he does
belong the only bit of believable
emotion in the movie I had to come back
Chile
I was happy Chile I really was just try
to remember me like that okay he's
giving a better brendan fraiser
performance than Brendan Fraser full
monkey bone tries to stop him through
rat races greatest hits though that
green screen was more convincing than a
special-effects film oh they both get
sent back to downtown I was just
practicing my fake excitement for when I
have to do Fyodor max the dancing real
monkey bone is left back in Fraser his
mind he goes back to the real world to
be reunited with Vonda trying to pretend
she gives a shit and let's go out of
what we know what the funny is part of
the movie people for the love of God
take off your clothes
[Music]
monkey bone is arguably the last of the
dark weird wild and crazy movies that
exists just to exist there's a good
reason it's the last one though because
it's done horribly well Fisher was an
imagination are stunning the lack of
focus on motivation comedy and even just
fun are completely misdirected
thankfully this director would do more
projects that were just as dark and
imaginative but this time Carrie charm
and intelligence along with it that's
what more weird and dark movies that
decided they want to be smarter too this
just leaves you mentally no like a hot
spatula pressing against your brain for
an hour and a half
I'm glad other imaginative and likable
ventures rose in the future but this was
certainly not one of them okay kids it's
time to go home well wait you're related
to those Gibson never seen my there's
more questions around here
[Music]
[Applause]
you
how are you
hey this is Doug Walker doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing action against hunger this is an
international relief and development
organization committed to saving the
lives of malnourished children and
families while providing substantial
access to safe water and long-term
solutions are recognized as a world
leader in the fight against hunger they
have pursued its vision of a world
without hunger for nearly three decades
combating hunger and emergency
situations of conflict natural disaster
and chronic food insecurity with
headquarters in New York London Madrid
on-trail and Paris their field staff
work in over 40 countries to carry out
innovative life-saving programs in
nutrition food security water and
sanitation health and advocacy if you
check out their site or their YouTube
page you can see how their programs
reach over four million people a year
they do amazing work and you can help
them do even more
take a look give a click and see if you
can help those who help others
you
[Music]